[Music]
the Islamic State or Isis doesn't
represent 1.5 billion Muslims many
Muslims have repudiated it however
30,000 Muslims from all over the world
have joined it because it presents
itself as the truest embodiment of Islam
and those who repudiate it have not been
able to counter its appeal the Islamic
state is self-consciously Islamic in
June 2014 a video circulated of a masked
Islamic State Commander telling a
cheering Crowd by Allah we embarked on
our Jihad only to support the religion
of Allah Allah willing we will establish
a state ruled by the Quran and the
Sunnah all of you honorable Muslims are
the soldiers of the Muslim State he
promised that the Islamic State would
establish the Sharia of Allah the Quran
and the Sunnah as the crowd repeatedly
responded with cries of Allah Akbar the
Islamic State's very public beheadings
have horrified the world in large part
they were responsible for the wave of
public concern about Isis in America
that led to the initiation of us Le air
strikes against the Islamic State many
have taken them the beheadings that is
as a sign for that for all its vaunted
media Savvy the Islamic State will
ultimately be undone by its own savagery
as the world will ultimately have had
enough of this horror and will move to
destroy Isis once and for
all why then does the Islamic State
behead anyone much less film The
beheadings and post them on social media
because from their standpoint beheadings
are a recruitment tool one that's rooted
in the Quran the Muslim holy book says
very straightforwardly when you meet the
unbelievers strike the
nexts the Islamic State knows that young
Muslims who are aware of that verse will
not recoil in horror and disgust from
their beheading videos but rather they
will realize that the Islamic state is
acting in Fidelity with the Quran thus
the beheadings will bolster the Islamic
State's claim to constitute the new
caliphate the beheading videos also
strike Terror into the hearts of the
enemies of Allah which is another quote
from the Quran thus as far as the
jihadis of the Islamic State are
concerned the world's revulsion and
disgust at their beheading videos are
only confirmation that they're on the
right track on December 15th 2014 the
Islamic State released a document
entitled clarification regarding the
hudud that is punishments Allah
specifies in the Quran this was
essentially the Islamic States penal
code and every aspect of it was drawn
from Islamic teaching the clarification
mandates death for blasphemy against
Allah or Muhammad it specifies that
murder with stealing will be punished by
death and crucifixion of the dead body
murder alone will be punishable by just
simply death stealing as part of
banditry will be rewarded with the
amputation of the right hand and the
left leg and terrorizing people will
result in Exile all these penalties and
more are derived from this particular
konic verse indeed the penalty for those
who wage war against Allah and his
messenger and strive upon the Earth
corruption is none but they be killed or
crucified or that their hands and feet
be cut off from opposite sides or that
they be exiled from the land that is for
them a disgrace in this world and for
them in the Hereafter is a great
punishment except for those who return
before you apprehend them and know that
Allah is forgiving and
merciful in fact every last one of the
Islamic States penalties line up with
the Quran and Muhammad's words in the
Hadith in so scrupulously carrying out
the commands of their faith the Muslims
of the Islamic State have sought to
butress their claim to be the new
caliphate it's the basis of their appeal